hallo mein name super nett ich bekomme
heute zu einem neuen video glaube ich
schon drei videos hochgeladen wo ich
youtuber an bestimmten merkmalen erkannt
habe wie beispielsweise youtube anderer
merkmale oder teilweise an den figuren
diese youtuber erkannt heute erkennen
wir youtube an ihrem mund
ja
würde hier klicken und sehen schon
erkennst du diese youtube ihren mund
halten m bahn de können diese leute nie
richtiges deutsch also nie zu normal
wieder eigentlich ein recht wieder kanal
deutschland musst du trotzdem mal sagt
der härte youtuber wer mittags sekunden
zeit ich mache aber ganz kurze pausen
damit will man eben hier überlegen
können also wir sehen ganz deutlich
diese person hat ein paar da heißt es
könnte babys beauty pellet sein
eines ist natürlich eine beauty youtuber
rinnen keine weibliche youtube ich würde
dazu tendieren schenk ist oder ich bin
mir überhaupt nicht wichtig sagt einfach
mal schenkel von prime 2 1 und ich
dachte das wäre komplett bald nie
gedacht dass der von helen bahn hat sag
ich mal weil er ja eigentlich eher der
dunkle frisur oder hat er überhaupt are
auf jeden fall geht es jetzt weiter mit
dem nächsten youtuber ich glaube da sind
wir uns alle einig dass david relativ
[Musik]
kennt nicht mal dass es katja l 50
prozent dieses bildes sind brüste und
das hier ist ihr mund und ich finde das
könnte auch der mund von queen david
sein aber wir machen mal weiter freundin
ist legal
aid
das seien man also wieder eine person
mit einem bart
dabei könnte wieder wie mit billy palace
sein ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher
wer das irgendwie sein können ich weiß
noch nicht ob das ganze hier nur noch
deutsche youtuber festgelegt jetzt unter
zeitdruck würde ich einfach sagen
born überhaupt keine ahnung
was scorpion vielleicht ich backe
scorpion und wir sehen jedoch
da wäre ich nie die wahrheit
draufgekommen weitergeht mit dem
nächsten youtube
das ist schwierig wie viele punkte habe
ich eigentlich wird er gelobt ban habe
ich einen punkt dafür bin mir überhaupt
nicht sicher ich würde mal sagen rief
weil der relativ entstellt
okay da wäre ich auch nie drauf
gekoppelt habe ich jetzt einmal
getroffen im echten leben das bleibt
immer noch bei einem punkt den ich
bisher habe das jetzt auf jeden fall
geht man mädchen und ich würde sagen
dass das dach oder melina die arminia
wird sich melina und regine
regina wäre ich niemals draufgekommen
also ich weiß nicht wie ihr kanal heißt
wieder irgendwie so also bleibt dabei
ich habe einfach nur 1 punkt weiter geht
mit dem nächsten youtuber und war dieser
hier
simon umgehe ich glaub da kann man
eigentlich relativ sicher sagen wie man
ungarn wir hier das ist sogar der köln
bonn airport im zwei punkte habe ich
bisher lief der youtuber hier würde ich
sagen
lena meyer landrut also ich sagt lena
meyer landrut ich glaube dass sie wurden
wahrscheinlich wird wenig sein
wer ist sarah sorry also jetzt nicht
böse gemeint aber ich kenne wie einfach
nicht wäre ich niemals draufgekommen der
mund ist für mich so ein bisschen aus
wie der mond von lena meyer landrut mein
gott mein vater unser hallo ich
quadratmeter auf
ja
vor bei dem hier bin ich mir überhaupt
nicht sicher ich würde sagen hongkong
dpa kritische tv
als wenn der sonnenbad hat es bleibt
leider dabei ich habe immer noch nur
einen punkte per hier in weder luna dato
oder luda darko in meinem auge von
richtiger 100 kubik die haare auch die
kaffee soll ich das denn rausfinden man
was sind das denn für zenimax
ich habe aber auch irgendwie noch ein
youtuber kommt nein das war es
das war's becker ich hab bei youtube hat
und so zehn stück oder so das fazit von
video meine damen und herren es euch
gefallen hat und ich das noch mal machen
soll mit irgendwie kennt die youtube an
ihr mörder irgendwie was man vielleicht
schreibe ich meine kommentare wie die
punkte ihr hattet wenn ich hatte aber
tun wenn man bei so einem kurs hat muss
man wirklich zugeben erschweren kann ich
mich normalerweise eher weniger und
jetzt würde ich sagen meine damen und
herren die zeit forderte zeit auf die
jeder gewartet hat
ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen kopf
stecken ihr findet ihr für andere
visionen wenn sie auch die glocken
glichen dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]